do you believe in UFOs astral projection
mental telepathy ESP clairvoyance spirit
photography telekinetic movement full
trans mediums the Loch Ness monster and
that there could possibly be a way to
save this franchise there's a steady
paycheck in it I believe anything you
say
so I yeah this is kind of a weird one to
talk about in terms of timing wise cuz
not really relevant anymore but you know
what it was on my mind so I saw a piece
where Paul Feig who directed the 2016
Ghostbusters said that he would actually
really like to make a sequel he said
that the year a little more than a year
ago when it started to become clear that
there was probably not going to be a
sequel but he stood by it and he's kept
saying it and he said some other things
that has actually made me go well should
there be one and if there is should he
direct it because I I don't think it's
as clear-cut as a lot of people made now
to refresh people's memory because I've
got way more subscribers than I did back
when I reviewed that film got it
I was still using the green screen back
then good grief
so the 2016 Ghostbusters I had problems
going in because it was a reboot I
didn't care that it was women actually I
think that was kind of a neat twist on
things but I didn't like that they throw
out the old continuity especially
because they didn't seem to be any need
to do that to tell the kind of story
they were gonna be telling so I had that
issue going in seeing the movie to the
end it didn't justify being a reboot so
that didn't work for me but it's not a
bad film it's okay it it started
clicking for me towards the end
basically through the climax when it had
your more legitimate of an action
sequence like in Times Square then
ghostbusters usually has I dug that I
like the character of paddy I liked
Holtzman the other two were okay they
they were fine they were decent enough
you know I liked Kevin the secretary
I've I thought that was kind of a fun
flip around on things and it what it
wasn't awful it's honestly it's
something that you could build off of
and the things that puffy has said since
the release of that film makes me think
it might be worth letting him try to
build off it now before I say this this
is not based on any presumption that
they will make us equal I think that is
incredibly unlike to my way of thinking
the only way Sony even considers a
sequel to Ghostbusters is if venom tanks
hard and they they go well crap we still
need a franchise let's Wow let's see if
there's any gas left in this
Ghostbusters tank failing that scenario
and even that is a that's a long shot I
don't see us actually getting a sequel
to this so this is all hypothetical and
I'm not gonna lay out what I think they
should do I will say that I don't think
that they should be trying to correct
the narrative I don't think they should
try and retro actively make this no
longer a reboot like that that ship has
sailed
so trying to go back and fix that it all
you do is bring more attention to the
fact that you screwed it up the first
time move on from it don't deal with it
so why do I think that it would actually
be interesting to see Paul Feig take
another crack at this well it has to do
with some of the stuff he said something
that he's basically admitted to since
that first film came out was that while
he was a fan of the original
Ghostbusters he didn't understand the
current fandom for it and what I mean by
that is there are kind of two sorts of
Ghostbusters fans there were people
around Paul Feig saij you know who were
already adults when the original film
came out and for them it was Wow you
know these guys from SNL made this
really funny kind of
movie based off stuff that they like
they know I'm not diminishing you know
their experience of watching it but you
know they watch the names learning and
their take on it was Wow
look at these funny guys and these cool
effects this is kind of neat but what he
hadn't understood at the time he made
the film was people my age who watched
the the that film out of every young age
and then steeped in ghostbusters through
the toys and the cartoons and the comic
books and this continuation of it we
really came to love it and I don't want
to say like at the same level but like
in the vein that people love Star Wars
so he did not understand that he didn't
appreciate that so while he was a fan of
the original his fan dump his type of
fandom meant that he approached it with
an attitude and came at it from a
position that basically ticked off fans
like me and he's admitted to not having
understood that at the time he made the
film so he seems to have a better
understanding to that now and you know
you would actually ask well if he has
kind of admitted to not getting it in a
way why would he want to make another
one well part of it is he has really
appreciated the reaction from people who
did like it often times so psyched young
girls who really enjoyed it and you know
it kind of tickled him when some of them
dressed up as the ghost busters for
Halloween probably mostly as Holtzman
because Holtzman's awesome and it has
the most iconic kind of a look thing
going on but he really appreciated it
enjoyed that and more recent comments
that I saw from him and kind of got my
wheels spinning about this was he also
admitted that turning the the lead-up to
the whole thing into kind of an event
and a cause was probably not the best
choice now that having been said you
know the fact that some fans were very
vicious needlessly Snow's needlessly so
about the fact that they are women and
who attacked that specifically and went
crazy about that
I'm not saying those people should be
placated because they were gonna hate on
it no matter what at this point once
that decision was made however the
film's seem to actively you know in the
process and the and the marketing and
the behind-the-scenes stuff seem to be
actively antagonizing them and even
though it's not a pretty part of the
fandom that was a part of the fandom and
there were fans who might have been more
on the film side but it seemed to be
lumping together anyone who had an issue
with the film in with the worst and
loudest people who did have a problem
with the film and so they tried to in a
weird way almost make it a rallying cry
against you know this kind of toxicity
and while I can understand why that
decision was made it it didn't endear
the project so you know when you do what
you do something that's going to tick
off of the fanbase or at least a
contingent of it and in general I don't
have a probably you know make your
choice just be prepared to deal with a
maybe it won't work but you know it's
one thing to make that decision and then
sort of go look we understand not
everyone's gonna like this but we feel
it's the best decision we hope when you
see it you'll agree and it's another to
start to make fun of people
and I understand that it's a tempting
target because again some of those
people who were complaining about that
the Ghostbusters are girls now and I
swear I saw stuff on Reddit making
arguments about how Ghostbusters could
never be women because their their
physical makeup would not allow them to
carry a proton pack like it it was
stupid and I don't have a broad inherent
problem with mocking people like that
but unfortunately they you know it's the
kind of thing where it's hard to make
you know to criticize or mock people
like that with a scalpel you tend to do
it with a shotgun and then you know you
end up hitting folks who maybe weren't
that bad but also we're a little like
wow we have concerns and you paint them
all with the same brush and
create it created a backlash that was
bigger than what it would have been if
they hadn't kind of poked the bear and
he's also basically fess up to that he
said it was kind of a mistake to try and
turn the film into a cause when it was
just supposed to be a fun movie I mean
that was what he set out to make and how
well he did or didn't succeed at that
you know that varies from from personal
person but he didn't set out to make a
cause event a rally cry movie but it
became that in the lead up and he did he
admits to having contributed to that but
Nene now says that probably wasn't
mistake now why I think it would be
interesting to see him take another
crack at this is because it's not very
often that we see corrective measures on
a franchise being instituted by the
filmmaker usually when you get notable
serious correctives on a series they're
usually studio mandates so an easy go-to
example a big part of why Zack Snyder
was brought in for Man of Steel versus
any other director and there was a big
push for somebody like him was they
wanted action in Man of Steel because a
big part of the response to Superman
Returns was that there wasn't enough
action in it so that was a that was a
corrective that was that was decided at
the studio level and anything that Paul
Feig is saying is not reflective of Sony
because as I said Sony is making no
indication that they're that they're
touching this property at all at this
point so it's it's obviously not you
know a studio mandate filtering down
through this director these are changes
he would like to make and it's not
especially often that you have a
director go look I tried this thing it
didn't work I'd like to try again and do
better you actually don't find that all
that often you know sometimes you know
that's not to say directors always
praying about the same thing you know
they'll make changes they'll make their
adjustments but they usually won't be
this degree of open about what did or
didn't work and what they hope to do
better in the future
and I I guess I guess I feel be kind of
ashamed to have this instance where a
guy made a film that I again I think is
fine it's a it's a perfectly okay film
that he came out of him went huh you
know now that I have talked to be more
and seen the reaction and kind of take
this step back from this there was a lot
of stuff I could have done better boy be
nice to try again I kind of want to see
what would happen if he did but like I
said we we probably won't we almost
definitely won't and I do feel that
that's kind of a shame because despite
my massive hang-up about the fact that
it was a reboot and there was absolutely
no need for it to be a reboot I you know
I don't like seeing properties that I
enjoy fail sometimes I think it's
necessary that they fail because it's
the only way to stop you know some of
the huge issues that might be going on
with them but I don't want them to I
don't you know I don't like the idea
that Ghostbusters is going to now be
more of a footnote because it now feels
like a dead franchise because the reboot
isn't going to be continued and there's
no way they can continue the original
because you know we lost one of the
actors and the remaining ones that
they're frankly a bit too old for it I'm
not gonna say ever got over the the 2016
Ghostbusters being a reboot but having
basically processed that and accepted it
as best as I can
yeah I would like to see them try and do
better try and have them be more their
own thing because that was another
problem with that film is by by
retelling the origin of how the
Ghostbusters came together it took
longer to find its own groove than it
should have whereas they could come into
a sequel with these character dynamics
established having a sense of what
didn't didn't work and really leaning
into that and I I think it's kind of
that that won't happen and I'm probably
in the vast minority of that cuz again
I'm not even a huge fan of that film but
I know lots of people out there were or
doing a victory dance
when that thing belly flopped at the box
office and at the time I was like no
okay and now I feel like it's just this
kind of a shame but yeah so those are my
weird thoughts on maybe it would be kind
of nice if it got a sequel but it
probably won't so just a random topic
something that came into my head what
are your thoughts on this do you think
there should be a sequel would you
prefer another reboot yeah I wouldn't I
I would rather have it slip off quietly
into the night and have another reboot
at least any time soon but you know what
whatever your thoughts are if you've got
a pitch drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's all
this stuff to do support me on patreon
follow me on Twitter bla bla bla bla bla
links in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]